hi I'm world-renowned handsome and
intelligent man markiplier and here at
cloak laboratories we are working hard
every day to bring you new elements of
the periodic table because we can over
the next five days we'll be showing you
these new elements in drops throughout
the next week all for you
now I'm no scientist but anyone can look
like a scientists if they compare
themselves to mr. jacksepticeye I have a
graph of his intelligence plotted right
here now if you compare the baseline
human intelligence an interesting
discrepancy is revealed and here's my
intelligence just for reference and
oddly enough if you overlay human
attractiveness a similar trend is
revealed with only minor discrepancies
but I'm going to put aside our vast vast
differences in both appearance and
intelligence and work together with
Shawn to bring you a new product but I'm
gonna need to use this bullhorn to even
get through that thick skull of his
Shawn could you come in here please John
me happy that you me work together Omni
doing good shirt it's good it is good it
good and it reminds me that you me do
good I'm gonna kill you
[Music]
alright wait so how do we get way it in
there is it just one on one where are
you oh hey hey is it literally just one
on one I think this is one on one I
didn't do that
we just did a single I don't know if
this is the intro screen I want to stare
at for forever listen listen whoever
wins this match the winner goes on to
face new Wade man how do I even do that
just like touches you touch don't stop I
don't like it stop it this game is
called punch to you in Ch guys okay the
targeting systems a little fun
it's [ __ ] nightmare what is this Oh
God I think the touching might be a
better strategy ah look if you're good
at commentaries very concerning it's not
good it's not good
it just said wrong way what does that
even mean I think you're about to leave
the area oh oh that was your love a whip
lucky that Hill was in the way oh I hit
that post take that post take that oh
[Laughter]
I'm just glad we found a fun multiplayer
game we could all enjoy together dude
man you never seen thickness of this
magnitude before in your life yeah yeah
that's a big rock you got there it is
thanks for give you free tool oh it's
gonna give you a free shot but now I
gotta get oh god you have all the rocks
on your side they're all over here but
it doesn't seem fair to me you know it's
the life isn't fair here I'll let you
I'll let you have one
I'll let you have one all right you
ready yeah so yeah I got your foot you
had your chance
Jesus guys this is like whenever you're
playing a co-op like split-screen game
back on console on the day like couch
gaming and like you and over lots for to
someone just kind of sits there on the
couch and his leg was good listen man
you go play then I'm gonna wait I wonder
if there's a way I know there's a way to
like watch don't see your game oh oh my
god I don't like the way you pick up
rocks run I'm on quite the delay but it
is let me tell you this is some
thrilling I've got you know what Marc I
could just stream this to you over
discord hang on oh no wait pause fine
pause well unpause okay
die [ __ ] you guys want to fight I'll
watch I'll watch you fight are there any
other buttons F and we're gonna stood as
buttons but I think X just sets down the
rocks is you take a prog-rock wait can
you accept boom you allow me to watch
the guns on a slight delay oh come here
wait come here just just come here I
wanna how how and why just the touching
help Oh God I like the magnetic leg
[Laughter]
alright yeah that makes sense
wait you could set the rock down by
hitting X yeah no but if I throw it
while he's engaged with me it just goes
through him here do it again it's I'm a
truck watch I'm so this game
like right so if I'm not facing you and
I'll throw the rock what Bob do you do
you have like an instant
you guys are touching each other right
now it's on my clock right now yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
serious conversation simulator move on a
bar with Jerry
[Laughter]
closing take my picture got it oh wait
I'd like no lady I'm gonna watch his
game yeah you should watch waiting I
guess I should well when you want to
fight wait it's me do you want to have
serious discussions what minute one one
it right now Wow I'm right on he was
this tall he was this shoulder
dislocated
oh no I I didn't mean to mount you you
just moved in on me yeah what could take
me from behind this your rock no that's
your rock this is is this really this
whole fair yeah all right let's so let's
do let's do that one more time hang on
now that more expansion did I buy it I
think I bought the expansion was it dude
go to CSUN you can change your dude if
you bought the expansion yeah yeah
you've got like roldugin ocean I want to
see what weights hang on to some
ridiculousness
why is your post changing what is
happening but none of these things do
anything down here
I'm just pouty incredulous Blaire why is
there a threshold of like a thousand 225
is that like a ranking system we have to
give points to like level oh I've gotta
be 225 to be point right and hypnotize
people with your nips yeah definitely
wait I can't see anything Bob I think
you're still watching Bob I think you're
still watching
I'll just imagine I got it guys I got it
all right okay I'm back in it okay hey
you can pick up two rocks Wow
yeah we figured out you could pick up
two rocks cuz you're so thick Wow this
spawn camping Wade now gonna get you
when are you trying to get one of these
rocks
one day my head is gonna be powerful
you just gotta charge straight down Wade
you don't know what a genius way to make
a game and half a 13 dollar expansion
bag for some stupid Express is because
I'm tempted to buy entirely I feel like
I really urge that draw there at the end
you sure did man you sure did I just
want one last game with Bob that's all I
wanted trusting trusting okay no hey
what's your time guys I'm at 314 or 256
can I go back the way
yes just saris this just feel too good
[Laughter]
12-pack of beer on a 30 pound bag of
rice 12 cans of kimchi
I want 14 Lamborghinis mm-hmm you better
hurry up we're gonna finish all right
here
here my mom go oh your your bones I'm
just so wimpy hey oh oh hey hey what a
sensual what a sensual hug look man I
can't believe this there I go cut it's
just if it's supposed to be sumo it
doesn't make a lot of sense because
aren't we supposed to push each other
out of the ring not just flap just die
yeah yeah it's it has been it's been a
couple weeks
twins separated at birth - it toufic
sold sorry I just know bud you really
are
that's how humor works okay the maureen
elect is responsible for our
understanding and utter mastery
improv comedy techniques our level of
hilarity is all thanks to Rachel
let me just know I slept ten seconds
left us before I find out who won well
you'll be shocked at the result
[Music]